fifteen minutes into this game tears
friends tears the Last of Us with
apocalypse scruff because it's necessary
so the Last of Us is opposed to POC
elliptic survival horror game brought to
us by the studio that gave us the
Uncharted series different creative
director behind the game you can still
tell this is the same studio that gave
us Uncharted and in the Last of Us it's
been 20 years since civilization itself
foul tells of this parasite that turns
people into weird parasitic zombie like
things that aren't actually undead but
they're still zombie like enough for me
to call them zombie ish people and now
there are quarantine zones you don't
feel like the entire government's fallen
there is still the presence of authority
in the United States at least but for
the most part yeah it's terrible and
Joel the guy you play as has to escort
this fourteen-year-old girl named Ellie
across post-apocalyptic America and from
there we have ourselves a sweet-ass game
first of all let's talk about the
graphics the graphics in this game are
[ __ ] up good there's so good I don't
think I've seen graphics this good on
the ps3 the lighting the shading the
motion capture of the characters the way
their facial expressions and their
mouths move to what they're saying they
feel like real people there's this
cutscene where you're driving a car and
the cameras looking in at you from
outside the windshield and it's raining
and the rains hitting the windshield
you're like that's rain like legit rain
I'm telling you this game looks great
the scenery in this game is crazy too I
mean when you're outside you're looking
up at the buildings the buildings are
all leaning on each other you're like
tits there's just nothing left of
humanity it's all gone it looks and
feels like the apocalypse after that the
game plays awesome familiar yeah awesome
absolutely the game is a survival horror
game it's almost like Naughty Dog was
like hey Capcom we're going to show you
something we're going to show you that
survival horror still works you don't
need to take your survival horror
franchise and turn it into an action
franchise watch a Last of Us slap is in
gameplay all top-notch most games like
this you either have your entire arsenal
that you've come across right at your
fingertips or they do the thing where
you can pick and choose two guns and
those are the guns you have to work with
this goes somewhere in the middle you do
have a couple guns that you have to
choose from among your arsenal but those
are just on your hotkeys you have the
rest of your weapons in your backpack
you can't just change them out at the
push of a button you can pick a couple
that you can change out out the push of
a button but if you're like alright I
want my pistol and my
shaaka not my rifle you have to hold X
he goes into his backpack and you put
the gun you want into your hotkey and
now you have those two guns to choose
from so you have your arsenal but not
all of your arsenal is on one button
change out it was a good way to do it
because it also makes sense if you're in
a post-apocalyptic world and you come
across a gun you're not going to be like
I'm sorry I can only pick two people who
do that or call dead people and the
crafting was really good - I hate
crafting in games
I don't rephrase that I usually hate
crafting in games because usually games
don't do crafting well it's usually this
long convoluted thing where I'm like I
could go through all that work or I
could just work with the weapons I have
I think I'll do that I'll go with that
option but in this game crafting is
pretty easy you get your scraps and you
combine them to make something the best
part about it is these crafted weapons
are really relevant weapons can anyone
out there argue me on the perspective
that the best weapons in the game are
the Molotov cocktail and the nail bomb
best weapons in the game then you use
them and you get more scraps you create
more of them stealth kills are great to
you you start getting really good at
stealth kills in The Last of Us ammo is
pretty limited not like unbearably
limited you do end the game with more
ammo than you need because you conserve
occurs only I need to conserve my ammo
so you get really good at stealth kills
and when you grab someone into a
headlock and choke him out a dude's just
struggling the way he's slapping your
head you're like I really feel like I'm
killing somebody did a really good job
at making the body language in this game
feel like real people even when their
eyeballs are rolling in the back of
their head and they're dying because
you're choking him out it's not murder
its justified it's the apocalypse kill
or be killed as cool as Joel was he's a
guy you play as he's damaged you can
tell that he's hardcore cuz he's been
among this shitty world for 20 years
until he's done some dark things to
survive but he's learned how to survive
back to the matter is friends Joel
doesn't steal the show Ellie does Ellie
was just awesome she's one of the
coolest characters I've seen in the game
lately the fact is if Ellie sucked this
game would suck we'd all be like on
escort game in which you got a pal
around with this annoying girl and why
am i playing this but the fact is
Ellie's awesome I love the fact that
games are now learning how to make
escort based games fun before we were
like escort mission in a game I don't
like this mission but in BioShock
Infinite this chicks just throwing ammo
for you like here I found these things
for you you're like best escort ever I
mean escort is in the mission not the
not saying she's an escort and now we
have Ellie Nellie's not like this really
reserved nice girl that you know is
going to get corrupted from the
situation she was born after a
civilization fell so she knows this
world she has attitude she swears she
says what's on her mind she has heart is
the word I'm looking for the girl has
heart she is the best young adult I've
seen in a game ever in my life yeah I'll
phrase it like that I don't think that's
offsides
I love character growth in this game did
character growth very well with Ellie
and I'm telling you in the game itself
there were a few times I was I was
welling up I was like sad just sadness
and it was sad but it was touching they
were just touching moments in the game
where you're like damn and everyone's
shitty in this game I think there are
all their [ __ ] there are a couple of
nicest people you meet in the game yeah
for sure but I guess the games so based
in reality that they can't be too nice
no one in this game is ever like I am
perfectly great human being and I'll
never era Tait you I like that I take
notes in this game I'm like okay
humanity Falls let's just look at the
Last of Us and then we'll go from there
a really cool thing about the fungus
parasite that wipes out humanity in this
game is that it actually is one that
exists in our world a variation of it
anyways based on a cordyceps fungus this
thing exists but it only affects ants
and bugs and the tropical rainforest or
some [ __ ] in this game it's now moved to
humanity but it's always really cool
when they take something that exists in
the real world may tweak and they're
like well I don't know maybe and if this
does happen it'll probably end up like
the Last of Us the multiplayer is pretty
fun it puts you as a person in these
factions in this world that is crumbled
you go around you do your missions I
play games like this not for the
multiplayer man I have fun playing the
multiplayer I never walk away from the
multiplayer gone that is totally what
the game is built around like that over
and over again I'm probably gonna play
New Game+ after I beat this game and
play through the game again but the
multiplayer is fun get a few friends get
some headsets and knock yourselves out
you'll have fun with it and then you'll
soon be like where's Ellie I miss her
and then you'll go back to playing
single-player the gripes I would have
about this game or a couple times there
were glitches I'm trying to knife
somebody and they're trying to knife
mean it's just like back and forth I'm
like okay well there's no one's knifing
anybody because the game's glitching out
but every game has glitches and it has
that Uncharted type annoyance to where
you get someone right in your crosshairs
and then they randomly they don't see
you but they just move you're like I
just got your head in the head shot
crosshair and you just moved at that
particular time I was using the bow and
arrow I love the bow and arrow you have
to get used to the bow and arrow so you
do need to practice with it to get good
with it but when you're good you're like
I'm Tarak the awesome I'm a go my
Legolas and then
I drew the bow and arrow back and I put
this thing right at this guy's head
there were a few people none of them saw
me they were all facing away from me
right when I got this thing on this
guy's head I was gonna headshot him he
and everyone else in the room just
dropped with the grounds like they went
down to tie their shoes I'm like right
then and there that's when you did it
come on game don't irritate me like that
[ __ ] know some people like remember they
did see you trust me I played through
the game I know the system of the game
they didn't see me that happens quite a
few times right when you get someone
right in your crosshairs like headshot
they'll somehow defconn wave is going to
get right there right on the crosshair
and then he stops and looks around and
maybe goes the other way or just looks
back and you're like dude just go right
into the crosshairs it's what you're
supposed to do if you were an oblivious
person like you are you would do that
why aren't you doing that in the end I
love the characters I love the graphics
I love the gameplay it's one of those
games I was playing I'll say oh man it's
ending and then you have another chapter
you're like yeah another chapter it's
not over yet this give me more game
players they're happy to do it the end
just kind of ends to where I personally
I was like can we just have one more
scene just extend that by one scene but
I get why it is I mean the ending
totally fits for the entire vibe of the
game The Last of Us was everything I
wanted the last of us to be and more as
I didn't expect Ellie to be off that's
why Ellie is in the front of the cover
because it is her game and The Last of
Us
is awesome tacular
haven't given that rating to a lot of
movies this year but it's good to give
it to games if I can break it down for
you it is like this it's like the
telltale Walking Dead game had a kid
with Resident Evil 4 two great games
came together to make one great game the
world is good today my friends because
we have the Last of Us
sorry so the last of us have you played
it and what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more